we have arrived
game four of this alds from picturesque
san diego california welcome from petco
park
the home of the san diego padres and the
home of this american league division
series randy rosarina
he has been on a tear making a name for
himself
in this postseason as has john carlos
stanton
an historic start to this 2020
postseason
yankees in the pinstripes this is game
four
yankees raise and that's the hurler they
will face
ron darling it'll be jordan montgomery
the big left-handed
big left-hander and he pitches big brian
straight over the top
with his fastball and good breaking ball
also has a little cutter
against right-handed hitters and a
change so a man on right away
here is brandon lau a struggling hitter
right now he's on the first pitch
bouncing right to first boyd steps on
the back
fire to second can't get a tag down and
it is in time for the out
nifty play by voight good feet and a
strong
throw that gave torres a chance to get
the tag down
randy arose arena he's homered in each
of the first three games in this
division series and a swing at a miss
that's a good start for jordan
montgomery after a lead-off single
double play ball and a strikeout eight
pitch inning
for the big lefty ryan thompson
will get the start ronnie set us up with
ryan thompson well he only opened once
this year
ironically it was against the yankees on
august 8th he went two innings to
give up a hit no runs here is aaron
judge
there's a swing adam is tied him up just
ran one
up and then on judge and committed to
swing down he goes and the first out for
thompson is a strikeout
it's going to be giancarlo stanton
coming up here with two away
and a swing and a foul tip right into
the bit of zunito that's a strikeout
and the opener ryan thompson does his
job
two quick outs two and two the count
and a swing at a foul tip into the mid
it's a strikeout and
montgomery finishes both innings with
kays
thompson deals to point and a swing and
a drive
that is way back and way gone
and voight knocks one out of here to put
the yankees
on the board first his first of the
postseason
a flip-flop in the batting order and
voight of no
doubter kevin cash gonna let this ride
still as le mayhew
comes back around here's the pitch le
mayhew in the air
right field margot under it makes the
play
tagging at third is gardner he'll score
easily
and dj le mayhew delivers a sacrifice
fly
two to nothing yankees there's the big
leg kick
and that's a fast ball that misses
walked him on
four straight it's a wobbly here in this
third inning for
jordan montgomery montgomery facing lao
big leg kick he deals it on the ground
lemay who's over gloves it throws a
second out there
a run will score though to have the
shift on made for an awkward setup
but they do get it out the yankees lau
with an rbi
and the rays are on the board for the
first time so runner at first for
stanton yarborough deals
shatters the back got a chance to turn
it here adamus falls down
short hop though to joy and you talk
about
turning lemons into lemonade the tampa
bay rays somehow get a double play out
of that
here's joey wendell now joy the runner
at first here comes montgomery
and a call strike three perfectly
spotted
jordan montgomery picks up a backwards k
diaz with a hit and a walk there's a
called
strike three right on the edge chad
green
burns one off for a strikeout and here's
brandon lau
and down he goes boy that was one
impressive inning by chad green
was up and down a couple of times in the
pin comes on and
blows right through the order of the
fifth so gardner with two hits and a
walk he's at first with one away for
gleber torres
and torres turns on one down the
left-field line that is hooking that is
up and it is gone a
booming home run from glamour torres
two run jack gleber torres makes it 4-1
yankees rosarina has never faced
a role as chapman until now a week and a
day ago
swaying at a miss 101 from chapman
[Applause]
you never know when they need you
there's a basement in the left field
and the stolen base is gonna lead to a
run as torres will score
it's an rbi single for higashiyoka
a two out two strike rbi single 5-1
yankees yankees are out away from
forcing a game five
and a swing at a miss and that's it 100
mile an hour fastball a strikeout to end
the game
and a roll this chapman picks up the
save he's got a win and a save in this
postseason
the yankees win it five to one and we
are
set up for a game five
winner go home